Herzlich willkommen beim Podcast-Ufo, auch an alle, die uns hören, über ... Das ist das Geräusch für Spotify, das ich jetzt immer mache. Hey Leute, heute bei uns zu Gast, Stefan Tingler. Mein Gott, und die Sache ist die, also, Stefan hat eine Menge erlebt diese Woche, davon wird er euch jetzt erzählt, ich werde mehr so nebenbei ... Geld verlieren? Ganz kurz, warum hast du überhaupt Geld? Ich habe gehört, dass du gestern deinen Geldbeutel, wie du immer sagst, verloren hast. Der ist jetzt weg, aber trotzdem hast du immer noch Geld. Du hast heute bezahlt, du hast heute allen noch eine Runde Beefy im Netto ausgegeben. Wo ist das ganze Geld her? Ich bin ja Kleingeldverachter, Verächter. Das heißt, ich komme nach Hause und das Erste, was ich mache, ist ja, dass ich meiningeld nehme und in einen grossen Waffeleimer werfe, wo früher Waffeln drin waren, da ist jetzt Kleingeld drin. Das heisst, ich habe eine ganze Menge... Alles kippt gerade um hinter dir. Was ist denn da los? Du sitzt und trotzdem kippt alles hinter dir, die ganze Welt kippt zusammen. Unser neuer Praktikant Bongo, äh, ja. Das ist eine Conga leider einfach. Das ist eine Conga? Das ist eine Conga. Nein, ach so, Bongo sind immer zwei, ne. Kleinere. Auf jeden Fall. Wir machen gleich ein Konzert. Wenn uns die Gags ausgehen, haben wir immer noch ein Kongo-Konzert. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mir ein Kleingeld, und es wurde mir gestern mein Geldbeutel entwendet. Das heißt, jemand anders hat ihn aus Versehen eingesteckt und ist dann nach Mexiko gefahren, was natürlich auch immer so die klassische, ja klar. Kann ich jetzt nicht glauben. Ich war im Louvre und dann das Bild, das ich dabei hatte, sah so ähnlich aus wie die Mona Lisa und dann ich dussel, hab ich die eingesteckt.
Dabei hätte man es doch merken können, denn meine hat keine Augen, nein, und die ist ein bisschen verpixelt, mein Gott.
Und dann habe ich die mitgenommen nach Mexiko und jetzt sitze ich hier mit dem ganzen Schlasserer Mazzel und auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt kein Geld und deswegen habe ich mein mitgenommen nach Mexiko. Und jetzt sitze ich hier mit dem ganzen Schlasserer-Massel. Und auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt kein Geld. Und deswegen habe ich mein Kleingeld angenommen. Und jetzt habe ich einfach heute mal... Wie angenommen? Ach so. Ich habe heute Morgen einfach mal so zwei Schaufeln Kleingeld. Mit so einem Eislöffel? Mit so einem Eislöffel. Ich habe immer so für so Gummibärchen, wo man sich so Sachen zuerst stellen kann. Da schaufle ich immer. Also ich mag Eimer, aber ich mag auch ganz gerne Schaufeln. Also ich weiß sowieso nicht, warum das gute alte Esswerkzeug die Schaufel.
Weil früher, im Mittelalter, hat man ja ordentlich geschaufelt.
Im Mittelalter gab es nämlich kein Besteck, sondern Brot.
Nee, was wir nicht wissen, man hat ja so kleine Katapulter um den Tisch.
Da hat man immer das Essen so reingetan, da hat man dann so einen kleinen Kurbel gedreht
und dann ist das Essen in deinen Mund geflogen.
Richtig.
Da hat man dann, da sassen immer alle Lagen auch, die sassen nicht beim Essen, die lagen mit offenem Mund die ganze Zeit. Und mit Glück hat man das, man hat nicht immer was abbekommen beim Essen. Mal hat man Glück gehabt und es ist so eine Ladung Klöße in den Mund gekommen, aber sonst nicht. Deswegen war zum Beispiel der König ganz dick, weil der ganz viele Sachen bekommen hat. Genau, da sind viele Katapulte, die Richtung aufgestellt. Und was mir mein damaliger Geschichtslehrer gesagt hat, dass dessen Lieblingsthema war Essen im Mittelalter. Jeder Geschichtslehrer hat so ein Lieblingsthema, kennt er sich gut aus, weil normalerweise, du bist ja nicht Geschichtslehrer, weil dich Geschichte an sich interessiert, sondern du denkst, alter, poloponesischen Kriege, mega geil, und dann nimmst du halt noch Erster, Zweiter Weltkrieg auch noch mit in das Studio. Ja, muss er halt, ist er dabei. Muss er halt sein. Da denkst du, ja gut, scheiss drauf, selbst wenn es um Napoleon geht, ich droppe immer so ein bisschen poloponesische Kriege ein. Auf jeden Fall war dessen Hauptthema Essen im Mittelalter. Und er hat immer erzählt, dass es da kein Besteck gab, sondern die mit Brot gegessen haben. Und die haben dann so ein Laib Brot genommen und da so dieses Mousse rausgemacht, den Teig, und dann hatten die so eine grosse Brotschaufel. Ach so. Nee, ich dachte jetzt, die machen dann... So, Möwen, eh, überhaupt nicht. Stefan, nein. Ich dachte, die machen in diesem Laibbrot, der ausgehöhlt ist, machen die dann so einen Eintopf drin. Nee. Dann kannst du den Topf noch mitessen. Nee. Ganz, ganz falsch. Dann haben die so ein Brot, dann ist eine Brotschaufel, eine Braufel nenne ich sie persönlich, aber das müsst ihr nicht machen, die haben eine Braufel genommen und haben damit dann das ganze Essen so geschaufelt und konnten dann sozusagen das Esswerkzeug gleich mitessen, was sehr praktisch ist.
Das ist auch cool, das ist auch Fun, das ist ein Fun-Faktor.
Aber habe ich schon mal die Geschichte erzählt, was unfassbar war? Und zwar hat mal bei genau dem Geschichtslehrer mal jemand ein Referat gehalten, Matthias, und das dann, der das Gag an dem Referat war, er wollte das Referat immer halten und kurz bevor er irgendwas sagen konnte, hat der Lehrer ihn unterbrochen und hat ihn daran erinnert, dass er das ja auch noch sagen wollte, so dass er sagt so, ja zweiter Weltkrieg. War das eine einschüttete Sache zwischen dem Lehrer und dem Schüler? Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht, sondern es war echt reiner Zufall. Es hieß dann immer so, ja und Napoleon war der Heerführer von, ähm, Matthiasias erwähnt bitte auch noch kurz, dass Napoleon der Heerführer von Frankreich war. Ja, von Frankreich, genau, und er hatte eine Armee aus, sagt, dass er eine Menge Soldaten hatte, aus Soldaten und so ging es halt immer weiter. Er war nur 1,5, sagt, dass er 1,65 groß war. Genau, und das war dann so der Running Gag und danach haben alle laut gelacht, weil es so lustig war, dass er immer das gesagt hat. Weil irgendwann der Volksimpsons angemacht hat. Jahre später hatten wir den Geschichtslehrer nicht mehr, der war Rektor, der war der Rektor der Schule und war auch tatsächlich Geschichtslehrer. Der hat es geschafft? Ne, der war damals schon Rektor, aber hat auch noch gesagt, Florentin will, will ich persönlich ausreden. Der Fun-Typ, der klamaukige... Nein, der war nicht, der war halt einfach nur ein Arschloch, der halt immer den unterbrochen hat. Ach, das war ernst gemeint von ihm? Ja, natürlich war das ernst gemeint. Das muss man aber mal erwähnen in dem Fusslose. Hä, ja, als ob ein Rektor dann Gags macht oder was, ein Lehrer. Lehrer sind in der Regel nicht lustig. Auf jeden Fall hat er ihn immer unterbrochen, kurz bevor er Dinge gesagt hat, das war das Ding. Und dann Jahre später hatten wir den Geschichtslehrer nicht mehr und dann hält dieselbe Person auch nochmal ein Referat über irgendwas anderes, über, keine Ahnung, Redoxverbindungen. und dann hält er das Referat und mitten im Referat, mitten im Satz geht der Lautsprecher an und es kommt eine Durchsage von genau diesem Rektor und unterbricht ihn noch mal. Jetzt habe ich nicht mehr Unterricht bei ihm! Jahre später und alle und die drei Leute, die sich noch daran erinnern konnten, haben wirklich gelächelt, also wirklich so kurz geschmunzelt, ganz kurz, weil das schon geil war, dass der einfach Jahre später wie so ein Geist der ihn verfolgt und immer später, auch irgendwann, wenn er seiner Frau einen Haaradseintrag macht, kriegt er so eine SMS oder so was oder einen Anruf vom Rektor. Ja, es ist gut. Aber diese Referate waren auch geil. Und auch wenn man so amerikanische Serien guckt, vermisse ich, dass es in Deutschland nicht diese Vulkane gibt. Weil in jeder Sitcom bauen die diese Vulkane, machen dann irgendwie mit diesem Backpulver und Wasser und so einem Scheiss, machen die dann so ein Zeug, dass dann da so rote Lava rauskommt und es ist immer das Ziel, dass es ausbricht und einigermaßen cool aussieht oder so. Was ja tatsächlich ein Versäumnis ist, weil ich ganz ehrlich zugeben muss, ich weiss nicht hundertprozentig, wie ein Vulkan funktioniert. Wissen die auch nicht, die wissen nur, wie Backpulver funktioniert. Das war bei uns immer so ein Streich in unserer Siedlung. Da hieß es dann so, ja, nimm mal so von dem Überraschungsei diese Inneneier, diese gelben Inneneier und dann kann man die so aufklappen und dann gibt es eine grosse Seite und eine kleine Seite, wenn du es vor Augen hast. Und dann hieß es, füll die kleine Seite mit Backpulver bis zum Rand und füll die grosse Seite mit Wasser bis zum Rand. Mit Nitroglycerin und dann schmeiß es auf ihn. Dann schmeiß es auf Frau Beckenbauer da hinten. Und dann die Idee war, dann hieß es, ja, mach die dann zusammen, schüttel das und dann halt es an deinem Ohr, weil das hört sich total toll an. So, das war immer so der Streich und natürlich explodiert es dann nach kurzer Zeit. Und Leute waren sind gestorben, weil es dann die halbe Schädelhälfte fehlt. Mein Vater erzählte immer die eine Geschichte, immer Weihnachten, wie er mit seinen, mit seinen Brüdern damals so Feuerwerkskörper um, also quasi immer das Schwarzblubraus gemacht hat und dann einen neuen Feuerwerkskörper gebaut hat und die dann schon wohl wissend, dass gleich was schiefgehen wird, auf eine Wiese gelaufen sind damit, das angezündet haben und dann waren einfach, es war ein bisschen zu viel, damals war die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen auch nicht so groß, auch in diesen Bollern und dann ist einfach so ein Krater übrig geblieben, das Rosenbett von Frau Meier komplett weg und die Scheibe einer benachbarten Telefonzelle war gesprengt. Wow, das ist eine geile, das war ein Krater einfach zu sehen und es gab richtig Ärger, aber das ist cool, sowas macht man nicht mehr. Heute sind die Streiche okay, ein bisschen Backpulver am Kopf. Ja, ja. Ein Freund von mir hat jedes Jahr so eine Box gebaut, so mit ganz vielen verschiedenen Feuerwerkskörner drin. Das habe ich auch immer gemacht, aber nicht so geil. Und das war dann wie so eine Choreografie. Der hat dann einen so eine Box genommen, so eine Lebkuchenpapierbox und dann hat er dann so eine Lunte und das war dann so eine Kettenreaktion. Und der stand immer mit so einem Schal daneben wie so ein Dirigent. Ja, genau. Und es klappt, es klappt. Genau, da war dann so eine lange Kettenreaktion und jedes Jahr wurde es krasser. Da waren dann so Raketen mit so drin, die nach links und rechts gesprüht, so übersprühen hier und da. Aber eines Jahres hat er es übertrieben und er hat dann alles vollgepackt mit einer ganz grossen Kettenreaktion und dann alle so, okay, geil, was wird's dieses Jahr, neuer geiler Scheiss, die Kurier für, was hat er sich überlegt, geil, und die Lunte brannte, es war einfach nur, BOOM! Alles ist gleichzeitig in Luft geflogen, riesengroße Exklusion und alle mit grossen Augen so, bravo, der ist gestorben. Bei uns, wir haben auch einen Freundeskreis, der Silvester immer komplett, heute die grosse Silvester vor, übrigens, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gemerkt habt. Frohes neues Jahr! Frohes neues Jahr, zehn! Und dann gibt es einen Freundeskreis, die ist immer ein bisschen übertreibend, die fanden immer rüber nach Holland und holen sich dann Börder. Diesen Freundeskreis gibt es überall, in jeder Stadt. Und dann haben die immer jedes Jahr so Dinge, die haben römische Lichter, die haben sogar so einen coolen Namen, die hält man fest, sind so wie so ein Stab, den man festhält und da kommen dann so Bälle raus. Die besten, die allerbesten. Und dann stehen die auf der Strasse immer so gegenüber und machen halt so eine Harry Potter-Koreografie, führen die halt auf, weil man das aufeinander halten kann. Es kommen exakt die gleichen Farben wie bei Harry Potter in den Filmen raus und es sieht einfach aus, als ob so zwei krasse Magier einfach so einen mega, major Kampf am Laufen haben. Was echt immer cool ist. Es ist auch gefährlich, aber cool. Ja, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Also diese Gruppe waren immer wir eigentlich in der Regel, weil wir haben aus Österreich, meine Oma lebt in der Nähe von Österreich, und dadurch konnten wir aus Österreich immer Böller importieren, die dort billiger und auch heftiger waren, weil die andere Sicherheitsbeschränkungen hatten und so. Und die hatten teilweise auch so Feuerwerkskörper, die dieses Basteln irgendwie befeuert haben. Also die hatten zum Beispiel so Raketen. Oh, pun intended? Wer weiß. Die hatten so Raketen, die nur aus einer Treibladung bestanden. Also normalerweise hast du die Treibladung und dann die Explosionsladung. Du kannst also zum Dranbauen was? Genau, das war einfach nur eine kleine Rakete mit einer Treibladung, die einfach nur flogen ist. Das heißt, man macht natürlich den Knallfrosch noch dran. Du machst dann irgendwas dran. Und man macht noch das kleine Besuch da dran. Ja, oder es war halt mir egal, wir haben dann irgendwie Papierflieger gebaut, aber da halt dann überall diese Treibladungen dran geklebt, weil die auch recht klein waren und so, und dann konnte man halt irgendwie krasse Sachen bauen. Oder wir hatten zum Beispiel auch dieses eine Spiel, das irgendwie haben wir alle Freunde in die Hälfte geteilt, und die eine waren oben auf einem Berg und die anderen waren unten auf einem Hang und dann die oben hatten dann halt so so Treibladung an sich durch.
Ja, die hatten dann so Metallrohre, wo man halt immer diese Raketen angezündet und reingesteckt hat und halt wie so eine Bazooka versucht hat, die anderen zu treffen.
Bazooka-Taktik.
Genau, und die andere Mannschaft musste den Hang hochrennen und immer wenn jemand getroffen wurde, musste er wieder ganz nach unten laufen und neu anfangen.
Musste er beerdigt werden.
Und so stand halt hier oben und ich habe auch noch hier über der Nase habe ich noch so eine kleine Eindellung. Auge nennt man das. Ja, und die ist da entstanden. Weil aus diesem Rohr ist da diese Treiblung rausgeflogen und dann war ein grösserer Brocken Funken. Da war dann irgendwie so ein kleiner Brocken Schwarzpull, was auch immer, ist sie mir dann genau da hingeflogen und hat dann noch da ein Stückchen weiter gebrannt und hat sich dann da so eingebrannt und so. Aber auf jeden Fall, das war das. Aber wie gesagt, dieser Vulkan, der fehlt einfach in Deutschland. Und dann haben wir, wenn wir Tag der offenen Tür hatten in der Schule immer, da musste man sich mal für irgendwas melden. Ich habe natürlich immer Chemie genommen, Chemie habe ich nichts mit am Hut gehabt, war auch nicht gut, habe nichts verstanden, aber die Versuche am Tag der offenen Tür, die man begleiten musste für die Viertklässler, die gekommen sind, um sich die Schule anzugucken, die waren immer lustig, weil wir mussten immer so diese Emser-Pastellen anzünden oder so, damit irgendwas noch drauf machen und dann werden da so komische, wie so kleine Gebilde, also wie so eine Schlange, die da raus erwächst. Das ist so mega Standard, aber immer ganz cool. Und dann habe ich mich halt immer dafür gemeldet, weil ich immer so cool fand, wie diese Schlange gebildet hat. Das war immer ganz geil. Die kleinen Kitties waren mega, mega erstaunt. Chemie ist eigentlich auch das einzige Showfach, das wirklich von der Show lebt, das einerseits so langweilig ist, dass du diese künstlichen Show-Elemente brauchst, um es irgendwie schmackhaft zu machen. Aber auf der anderen Seite wirklich so Pyrotechnik und Show. Also bei keinem anderen Fach sagt man, okay, wir gehen da hin, um uns anzuschauen, weil irgendwie der Englischkurs sagt dann halt, hello, ist das ein Umbrella? Und die Leute denken sich, ja, muss ich das jetzt lernen oder nicht, brauche ich das? Nee. Ja, richtig. Es lebt davon, weil es hat... Es lebt von Blenden. Genau, es kann englisch extrem scheiße oder extrem geil sein. Natürlich kommt man immer in den Raum mit der Erwartung, bitte entflammen heute was. Heute kommt der Explosionsversuch dran, oder? Ja.
Und wir hatten immer vorhin eine Frau, Frau Pohl hieß, die war schon sehr alt und hatte immer eine Alkoholfahne.
Und die hat immer unter der Abzugshaube geraucht und man kam immer rein in den Raum und sie stand halt unter diesem Abzug, der mitten im Raum steht ja immer in so Chemieräumen und dann stand sie da eben halt gepafft, das war immer ziemlich lustig.
Aber Chemie ist geil.
Ja, das ist schon ganz geil eigentlich.
Chemie ist mehr gut.
Ja, aber schwer auszusprechen. Chemie. Chemie. Du sagst Chemie, was sagst du noch? Kamel? Kamel, ja, Chamäleon. Aber ich war, ging in Bayern zur Schule und da, was man da beim Tag der offenen Tür in Chemie gemacht hat, war Bierbrauen. Einfach so. Ich weiss bis heute nicht, ob das echtes Bier war oder ob das nur so...
Na, na, was schon, weil ich sage euch, es gibt gar schlechtes Bier, weil jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein gutes Bier zu brauen. Und ich weiss bis heute nicht, ob das echtes Bier war oder ob das nur so eine chemische Verbindung war, die so gelb und dann geschäumt hat, schaumende sagt man in Chemie, dass es dann so aussah wie ein Bierchen oder ob das tatsächlich Bier war. Weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man irgendwie aus Phosphorsäure und Montagan und einem Zott Monte oder so halt einfach ein Bier herkriegt, aber vielleicht geht das. Ich glaube, in Chemie geht alles so, weil das ist ja auch merkwürdig so. Das war so seltsam. Irgendwann war ein Chemiebaukasten über und dann wurde ausgelost. Die Frau, die mal unter dem Abzug geraucht hat, hat ausgelost. Und wir haben sie alle nicht so richtig verstanden. Sie hat auch ganz komisch deutsch gesprochen. Es war ganz seltsam alles bei ihr. Alle haben sich immer nur lustig gemacht, aber hier die Noten wurden zugelost. Und dann hat sie ausgelost, wer diesen Chemiebaukasten bekommt. Was ist schon, die sind ja gross, von Kosmos, die sind ziemlich teuer, die kosten etwa so 120 Euro, wenn die kauft. Und dann habe ich gewonnen. Und dann musste ich mit ihr in das Labor gehen und dann hat sie mir aufgefüllt. Und dann hat sie mir Aceton und dann ist sie losgelaufen und hat mir Aceton da reingemacht. Und dann, es hat sich richtig Mühe gegeben mit diesem Chemiebaukasten, den ich dann nach Hause gestellt habe und gegangen bin und nie wieder eingeguckt habe. Aber es tat mir dann auch ein bisschen leid. Ich glaube, ich habe dann mal irgendwie so, einfach mal aus Scherz irgendwie so ein bisschen Blausäure gemacht, einfach um ein bisschen das Gefühl zu geben, ich habe mich damit beschäftigt. Ja. Wie funktioniert ein Spiegel? Also weil Weiss, die Farbe Weiss, ist ja deswegen Weiss, weil sie alle Farben reflektiert. Aber warum sieht man dann in Weiss, die Farbe Weiss ist ja deswegen Weiss, weil sie alle Farben reflektiert.
Aber warum sieht man dann in weissen Oberflächen nicht wie ein Spiegel, wenn ja alle Farben, also alle Informationen, die hingehen, gehen auch wieder weg, aber warum sieht man dann nicht wie ein Spiegel bei Weiss? Ja, finde ich auch eine spannende Frage. Das ist aber so ein Conversation-Ender, weil ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich darauf reagieren soll, weil es wird gerade aufgenommen, was ich sage. Normalerweise im Leben würde ich jetzt was behaupten. Was würdest du denn behaupten? Also das ist ja interessant. Ich würde behaupten, es wird alles zurückgegeben von Weiss, und beim Spiegel wird nicht alles zurückgegeben, sondern nur das, was du auch siehst, was das Menschliche Auge sieht.
So einen Scheiss würde ich dann sagen. Und Leute würden meistens sagen, ja, das macht schon Sinn, ja, stimmt.
Aber wohingegen, sondern nur das, was du auch siehst, was das Mensch dir Auge sieht. So ein Scheiss würde ich dann sagen. Und Leute würden meistens sagen, ja, das macht schon Sinn.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber wohingegen, wenn ich das jetzt sage, kommt wieder der Mensch von WordPress und der sagt dann wieder, nein, ich studiere Spiegel im achten Semester und das funktioniert so und so.
Die Orientierung im Gebäude ist extrem schwierig, aber oft finde ich den Raum nicht, aber es geht schon.
Also die ganze Uni ist ein Spiegelkabinett, wir haben alle ein riesen Problem.
Manchmal haben wir lustige dicke Bäuche.
In der Cafeteria, aber das ist immer lustig.
Das ist immer lustig.
Das ist wirklich lustig.
Wie lustig muss man sein, um sich wirklich solche Sachen auch zu Hause zu installieren?
Also wie wichtig ist einem der Gag, dass man so einen Spiegel mit dicken Bauch zu Hause installiert? Zu Hause sind Gags ganz fehl am Platz. Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ja, und scheiss, man hat Teppiche, Teppiche sind ironie-los. Das Gegenteil von lustig. Warum haben wir kein Bällebad, also dass man so zum Bällebad kriechen muss, um im Bett zu landen. Ja. Genau, was ich auch eine geniale Szene bei Men in Black 2, glaube ich, finde, ist diese Szene, wo die Was ist die Filmempfehlung für heute eigentlich? Ja, Men in Black 2 ist der heutige Film von Stefan Tietze. Film Tietze. Ja, und da gibt es diese Szene, wie er noch vier Minuten Zeit hat, um diese Frau loszuschicken und dann kämpfen muss, aber er kann halt nicht, er ist halt in dieser grossen Luftpolsterfolie und kann sich halt nur so ganz langsam vorbewegen. Und er ist halt gefangen, obwohl das natürlich ziemlich ungefährlich ist und so, aber er kommt halt nicht raus, weil er kann sich nicht fortbewegen. Und warum hat man nicht irgendwie, warum ist das Bett nicht in einem grossen Luftpolsterraum und man kann halt, man braucht halt ewig morgen zum Bad oder so. Das finde ich lustig, wenn es einfach so ein Hindernis wäre. Man muss sich so durchkriechen die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Ja, ich habe ja ein lustiges Poster in meinem Zimmer hängen von Fischen.
Und das ist letztens runtergefallen von der Wand.
Und da dachte ich mir, oh gut, wenn du keinen Bock auf Comedy hast, dann lassen wir es.
Dann lassen wir es halt so.
Dann hänge ich da halt irgendwas anderes hin und dann lassen wir es.
Ich kann doch mal ein Pulp Fiction-Poster einbieten.
Das ist die niedere Schiene der... Nee, aber da wo du gerade von Fischen sprichst. Ah, das tut mir leid. Das ist ein bisschen gemein jetzt. Also ich muss sagen, die Podcast-Ufo-Hörerschaft muss jetzt sehr stark sein. Er ist noch nicht gestorben, uns hätte ich eine Aktion überlegt heute. Ich hätte mit dem Schlafen eine Aktion überlegt, vielleicht dass man irgendwie so ein Kondidenbuch eröffnet für Jeff und meinen Kampffisch. Aber er lebt halt noch. Also das Timing ist auch im Tod. Auch im Tod ist das Timing scheiße. Wie geht's ihm denn jetzt immer? Ich glaube, er liegt nur noch am Boden, ihm geht's nicht mehr so richtig gut. Ich glaube, er stirbt an Altersschwäche, weil ich habe ihn schon relativ alt bekommen und die werden halt nur zu zwei Jahre alt, diese Art. Und der ist jetzt ein Jahr und
ungefähr zehn Monate alt und ... Uiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
Wie viel Schuld rechnest du dir selbst an diesem vorstehenden Tod an? Eine Menge. Ich dachte auch erst, oh fuck, habe ich ihn gefüttert die letzten Tage,
habe ihm dann noch was gegeben und da habe ich dann ein bisschen erleichtert festgestellt,
dass es nicht der Hunger war, der ihn dazu antreibt, am Boden zu liegen, weil er hat nichts davon genommen.
Hat er denn ein schönes Leben? Und da habe ich dann ein bisschen erleichtert festgestellt, dass es nicht der Hunger war, der ihn dazu antreibt, am Boden zu liegen, weil er hat nichts davon genommen.
Hat er denn ein schönes Leben?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was für ein Fisch so ein schönes Leben ist.
Was waren denn so Highlights? Also wo sind so Dinge, wo du dich immer gerne zurückerinnerst, du und er?
Ich glaube, das Highlight war, wo er geliefert wurde in seiner Box und eine Woche lang da drin saß, weil er von Taiwan geschickt wurde und dann so ein lachender Grinsekopf ihn um nachts, weil er endlich bei den Nachbarn den Fisch abgeholt hat, die Box aufgemacht hat und ihn glücklich empfangen hat und dann in ein tolles Aquarium getan hat. Ich glaube, das war so der beste Moment. Natürlich auch die lang ausufernden Masturbations-Sessions sind sicherlich für beide von uns immer interessant gewesen. Die Filmabende, die wir zusammen verbracht haben, findet Nemo fand der super. Klar, wobei er weiss natürlich, dass er nicht ausbrechen kann, weil das so funktioniert in Aquarien nicht. Das ist gefährlich. Das ist immer so, wie wenn man im Gefängnis zeigt, man irgendwie Shawshank Redemption oder so Ausbruchsfilme, wo man einfach sagt, das ist so schön, endlich wieder aus dem Gefängnis raus sein.. Und denkst du dir, können wir noch mal Star Wars sehen oder sowas? Oder Shrek, Shrek 2. And then I saw her face. Now I'm a believer. Not a single trace. I died in my mind. Gut, zurück zu meinem toten Fisch. Noch ist er nicht tot. Nein.
Noch ist er nicht tot.
Es ist ein bisschen Schrödingers Fisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob er tot ist. Er ist gerade zu Hause. Wir sind hier im Turnstudio.
Ja, stimmt. Er könnte jetzt schon tot sein.
Er ist gerade zu gleichen Teilen tot und lebendig.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, er hat ein schönes Leben. Ich hätte mit ihm eine schöne Zeit. Das Aquarium werde ich auflösen. Ich hasse es. Die Schnecken haben komplett überhand genommen. Es ist ein Riesenproblem.
Aber wo wir gerade bei Musik waren, ich war am Wochenende auf einem The Who-Konzert. Wie cool ist das denn bitte? Nein, The Who. Ich war am Wochenende, ich bin aus Versehen The Who, ich bin aus Versehen bei Spotify auf Konzerte gekommen. Ganz neu. Ich wollte ein neues Album anhören und plötzlich war ich in Portrop, stand da in so einer Obihalle und ja, man begann zu spielen. Und es war, genau, und die Verkäuferin von Footlock, Lady Footlocker sah fast so aus wie Roger Daltrey. Nein, aber ich war wirklich da, ich war wirklich in Oberhausen bei The Who. Ich habe gehört, dass es morgen ein Konzert ist, habe dann einen Kumpel, von dem ich weiß, dass er auch die Musik hört. Und dann haben wir zusammen gefragt bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen, da hat jemand, weil das waren natürlich nur ältere Menschen da, Es waren jahre jahre alte menschen die an der standen die beste zeit ihres lebens hatten noch mal und wir halt und es war einfach eine coole zeit mehr konzert es war echt grossartig das war wirklich eine zeitreise vor allem war die hui auch damals ich weiß nicht ob ihr da draußen freaks and geeks geguckt habt von meinem freund judd apatow ah juddy joddy Abaddon, Joneer, mehrerer Megaserie, mit den ganz grossen und
wer ist dabei? Sarah Silverman ist dabei, Sarah Silverman ist dabei, die ganzen grossen Leute. Stefan Spiesler ist dabei, Günter Grassler, alle sind dabei. So, und die haben alle mitgemacht dabei. Und da war es in einer Folge ein Riesenskandal, da wollten nämlich die Kiddies unbedingt zum The Who-Konzert. Und es war damals halt so eine Skandalband und crazy. Und die Eltern haben sich die Platten angehört, um die Texte zu verstehen und haben es den Kindern nicht erlaubt, da hinzugehen zum Konzert. Und ich will mir einfach Karten bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, bin dann da und nur 70-Jährige. Das war ziemlich lustig eigentlich. Aber geil, also gute Band, kann ich jedem empfehlen. Was ist denn heu... also das hört man immer häufiger so, dass die ehemaligen Rebellen sind jetzt das Establishment, so von wegen die, die damals für Rock'n'Roll kämpfen mussten, sind heute die langweiler Rock'n'Roller, die man nicht mehr hören will.
Was ist denn das heute, was ist denn heute so tabu und verboten?
Weiß nicht Hip-Hop?
Gar nichts eigentlich, ne?
Hip-Hop?
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor Hip-Hop. Hip-Hop ist mir so ein bisschen suspekt.
Bisschen aggressiv.
Ihr ist immer so aggressiv und beschimpft sich immer. Das ist mir nicht so harmonisch genug. Deswegen mag ich den Michael Moor, der immer so alle sind cool, toleriert alle Menschen. Die finde ich gut, ja. Der ist cool, der macht Ur-Cro. Der erzählt auch von schönem Leben. Aber alle anderen, die beleidigen sich nur, das mag ich nicht. Das finde ich nicht gut. Was hast du so für Musik? Elektro, da ist gar kein Text. Elektro, ja. Bald ist in Köln ein Konzert. Wo du bist, wo du Fans trist. Vielleicht habe ich auch einen kleinen Auftritt. Ha, will nicht zu viel sagen, aber ... Musik, geile Musik und schlechte Stand-Up-Comedy, heute. Also ob und na. Das Konzert fing an, es gab auch eine Vorband, aber davor lief die ganze Zeit eine Dia-Show durch, von den besten Momenten der Band. Und so war auch die ganze Zeit, zwischendurch wurde immer eingeblendet, bitte unter gar keine Umständen rauchen, weil Roger leidet an einer Allergie und der könnte, da müsste er dann abbrechen. Rock'n'Roll! Yay, Baby, die Skandalband, lautestes Konzert im Guinness Buch der Rekorde. Könnt ihr bitte nicht so lang klatschen, weil die müssen dann auch noch aufrechterhalten. Aber er hat leider eine Rauchallergie, das ist auch so schade, ey. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist so echt ein bisschen uncool. Ich glaube, das ist für so einen Rock'n'Roll-Star vielleicht noch härter alt zu werden, wenn man diese ganzen Sachen nicht mehr aufrechterhalten kann. Und diese Nachricht kam nach dem Bild, wo eine Blüten, eine Gitarre gezeigt wurde, wo an dem Moment, wo man anschlägt, an dem Ort, Blut war, weil die nicht einmal nach dem Konzert so blutig gespielt haben. Und danach kam, Roger hat eine Rauchallergie, also auf keinen Fall Rauche, ciao! Aber hat man nicht ein Klektrum in der Hand? Ja, aber wenn du voll im Next-Hardel bist, dann reisst du dir auch schon mal einen Fingernagel ab. Ist mir auch schon passiert. Kein Problem. Weiß ich noch. Mein Gitarrenlehrer hat mal erzählt, ich weiß nicht, ob es er oder ein Kollege oder Goofy war oder je nachdem, bei einem Gitarrenkonzert wollte jemand bei so einem ganz klassischen barocken Stück oder so vermeiden, dieses Geräusch, wenn man auf einer Seite die Seite entlang zieht, dieses Quieken. Das ist ein bisschen so ein ... Nee, nicht, dass die Töne aneinander gebunden werden, sondern einfach dieses Quieken. Dadurch, dass die sechste, fünfte, vierte Seite ja so Rillen haben, dann knarzt es ja so ein bisschen. Und deswegen hatte er immer seine Finger voller Vaseline und dann hatte er so an dem, also wo der Schaft in den Korpus geht, da an diesem Winkel, hatte er so einen ganzen Batzen Vaseline einfach zu kleben. Aber wenn du für Winkel noch ein besseres Wort hättest. Wo der Schaft den Korpus mit dem Bröner trifft. Also im Bröner. Also er hatte den ganzen Bröner voller Vaseline. Und einfach war dann ganz gut darin, die Arpeggien zu spielen und so was und er konnte dann einfach da runter und das war, mein Lehrer hat das so beschrieben als, es klang sehr schön, aber das Publikum hatte so einen konstanten Ausdruck des Ekels im Gesicht, weil er halt wirklich immer wieder in diese Vaseline reingebaut, weil er musste halt auch ... Die Intention des Komponisten, alle haben konstanten Ekel im Gesicht. Weil er hat natürlich auch sehr schnell gespielt, weil er ein guter, krasser Genaunenspieler war. Aber er musste halt immer wieder in diese Vaseline rein, weil er halt irgendwie so ein Besessen davon war, dieses Geräusch, dieses Ziehen zu vermeiden. Aber ich weiss nicht, wie das hier geht, aber wenn ich jemanden, angenommen, ich sehe einen sehr cleveren Menschen bei einer Vorlesung zum Beispiel, und dann liest er einen wahnsinnig tiefgründigen Text durch, macht aber immer diese Geste, wo er, wenn er zum Umblättern, seine Finger mit der Zunge anfeuchtet. Ich kann Ihnen nicht mehr folgen. Es ist vorbei. Ich sehe nur quasi, wie sein Speichel an jeder Seite hängt. Ich finde das furchtbar. Ich habe das bis heute auch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden, warum man das gemacht hat. So bei so Glossy-Paper, so Magazinen, da verstehe ich das, weil da bleibt ja deine Finger kleben und dann kann man das so runterziehen. Aber bei Papier habe ich das noch nie verstanden, warum man das macht. Das bringt doch gar nichts. Ich habe mal ein Praktikum gemacht während meiner Schulzeit im Einkauf, im Einkauf einer Firma und da hatte eine Frau so einen Fingerhut, also so einen Gummihut auf dem Finger, weil die so oft mit Papier in Verbindung kommt, weil du so oft Akten durchgucken musst, dass ich halt diesen Fingerhut brauchte, um die Haftung zu haben. Und dann habe ich den manchmal bekommen, weil ich das auch machen musste. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich will nie wieder in einem Job leben, wo du etwas so oft in Verbindung mit dir kommst, dass du dafür etwas brauchst, was ein Körperteil von dir. Also dein Körperteil reicht nicht mehr, du brauchst, das ist wie ein uncooler Cyborg, so einen Gummifingerhut, was du brauchst, um Saiten durchzulittern. Aber ich sitze jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag nur rum und mache Papierkram und so, nein, überhaupt nicht, aber nehmen sie doch mal lieber diesen Gummihut. Und noch eine andere Idee, warum haben die bei Herr der Ringe etwas cooles genommen wie ein Ring und nicht so einen Fingerhut?
Das sind gute Fragen. Die hätten alle immer so einen ulkigen Fingerhut.
Ja, kann man halt nicht gut im Hals binden.
Klar.
Nee, der Hut hat ja kein Loch.
Ja, aber kannst du ja...
Ach so, ein Ring ist eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Glaubst du, das war die Herangehensweise?
Ja, natürlich.
Was kann man cool an Hals binden?
Die hatten immer Sean Bean vor Augen, wie er den Ring greift, wie er da so aus der Tunika rausfällt.
Ich habe da heute eigentlich Fachbegriffen, ich habe auch schon Redox-Reaktionen gesagt und es ist sogar so halbrichtig. Also, ich möchte nicht sagen. Das ist nicht schlecht. Hey Tonmann Kai, können wir kurz hier aufnehmen? Ja, ich habe ihn vorhin schon gefragt. Achso, okay. Alles klar. Ich möchte... Du wolltest mit mir über Küchen reden, in Wohnungen reden? Nee, weil du vorhin über Wohnen gesprochen hast, von dem Wohnungen einrichten und so. Ich wohne halt schon sehr lange mit Wohnmenschen, Wohnmitbewohnern zusammen. Ja, eigentlich bist du verunsichert, aber das Wort Wohnen erst an zweiter Stelle kommt. Und ich bin einfach der schlechteste Mitbewohner der Welt. Also ich bin der schlimmste Mitbewohner der Welt, grauenvoll, weil ich klaue, ich stehle.
Gut, das mir jetzt zu sagen, weil wir kurz zusammengezogen werden. Das wäre, ich denke, es vergeht kein Donnerstag, an dem ich nicht daran denke, wie es gewesen wäre, wenn wir damals zusammengezogen wären, als ich nach Köln gezogen bin.
Ich glaube, wir hätten zwei Filme geschrieben, wir hätten schon einen Emmy gewonnen aus Versehen.
Und bei beiden hätte jeweils der andere behauptet, er hätte ihn geschrieben.
Ja, wir hätten einen Emmy gewonnen, wir hätten das Podcast-Ufo-Gabes nicht mehr, es gäbe schon acht andere Projekte dafür, die alle gescheitert werden, wir hätten schon einen Skandal ausgelöst, weil wir uns gegenseitig gehasst haben, dann sind wir wieder, dann hätten wir vielleicht kurz geheiratet, dann sind wir wieder geschieden, es wäre alles passiert, diese ganzen Dinge, ich glaube, es wäre komplett, es wäre so eine Comedy-Explosion in Köln. Dafür hätten wir zwei weitere Film-Podcasts, einen Film-YouTube-Channel, wir hätten eine 24-7-Webcam auf uns. Das war wirklich meine Idee. Wir hätten eine Jeff-Cam oder sowas den ganzen Tag. Einfach komplett den ganzen Tag rausballern. Aber ich bin tatsächlich der schlechteste Mitwunder der Welt. Du stiehlt? Ich stiehle, ja. Essen? Ja, auch. Aber es ist zum Beispiel so, ich bin auch in meiner WG noch nie an die Tür gegangen, als sie geklingelt hat. Moinig. Auch wenn du alleine bist? Ja. Ist nicht für mich. Aber es sei denn, du erwartest ein Paket. Wird mir da nicht hingeliefert, es wird in die Arbeit geliefert. Aber ich gehe einfach nicht hin und ich stehle auch Essen und das ist wirklich sehr beschämend. Aber es ist wirklich so, ich klaue Sitzigkeiten, ich habe keine Selbstdisziplin. Die einzige Möglichkeit, wie ich abnehmen konnte, ist … Das hat nichts an mir Selbstdisziplin, das ist schon Moral. Ja, gut, ja, aber Moral schlägt halt oft in das niedere Triebe. Und es hat auch so, ich konnte nur deswegen abnehmen, weil ich den Moment der Disziplin verschoben habe, von zu Hause mit der, du hast noch eine Tüte Fritt im Regal, zu ich bin im Supermarkt und kaufe die Fritt erst gar nicht. Erst als ich in meinem Kopf den Schalter umgelegt habe zu sei stark im Supermarkt von sei stark zu Hause, aber dann ging es, weil wenn ich es gar nicht kaufe, dann darf ich halt und habe nichts. Aber sobaliv, dass ich, wenn ich, ich bin angewidert, auch nach dem Essen hasse ich Essen. Und dann bin ich so angewidert von Essen und dann gehe ich einfach und kaufe ich überhaupt zu wenig. Es ist nicht so, dass ich dann davon leben könnte in der Woche. Wohingegen, wenn ich hungrig in den Supermarkt gehe, dann tschau, dann ist die Karte. Das ist wie wenn du nach Masturbieren Instrumente einkaufst. Dann bist du rationaler, dann kaufst du nicht einfach irgendwas ein, sondern du bist klar. Du meinst, ich hätte die Posaune nicht gekauft, wenn ich davor noch mal ordentlich... Ist meine Theorie, also nicht meine Theorie, aber es ist eine Theorie. Wessen Theorie? Auf jeden Fall, ja ist ja schlimm und letztens gab es eine Situation, die kochen dann auch oft, ich koche ja nie, ich mache mir Spinat warm oder so, aber ansonsten gar nichts. Und demnächst ist gekocht und es war dann echt so eine seltsame Situation, weil die haben gekocht und hatten noch was übrig und ich habe gerade gezockt oder sowas. Und dann kam eine Mitwohnerin an und hat gesagt so, ähm, äh, wir haben... Du musst doch immer auslosen, wer dich anspricht. Wer geht rein, ich will nicht nur wieder. Wer klopft an einer Tür mit dem Danger-Symbol?
Danger, Teeny Zone, Florentin Zone, keep out, high voltage, grrrr, Bild von so einem Tiger. Und dann haben die gerade gekocht und ich hatte auch gerade was zu essen. Und dann kam sie in mein Zimmer und meinte so ganz kurz, wir haben gerade Reis mit... Oh, sehr nervös. Wir haben gerade Reis mit Brokkoli gemacht.
Sorry, sorry, nicht lang.
Möchtest du auch was? Und ich nur so, nee, ich hab schon, danke.
Und dann sie so, ja okay, das muss ich mir aber merken.
Mach die Tür zu.
Und dann erst mal so um 21, 22, Moment mal.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Wie hat die das jetzt gemeint?
Also Theorie eins, sie war so nervös, mit dir zu sprechen, dass ihr einfach irgendein Satz rausgerutscht ist. Theorie zwei, sie will sich merken, dass du schon immer ist, alleine für dich. Theorie drei, die in Zukunft sich nicht mehr anzubieten, falls sie es frech findet. Theorie vier und die, für die ich mich am Ende entschieden habe, ist, als ich gesagt habe, nein danke, ich hab schon, ist sie davon ausgegangen, ich hätte mir bereits ohne Erlaubnis was von ihrem Essen genommen. Wie hast du es denn gesagt, nein danke, ich hab schon oder nein danke, ich hab schon. Nee, danke, ich hab schon. Äh, mach mal. Nein, danke, ich hab schon oder nein, danke, ich hab schon. Nee, danke, ich hab schon. Mach mal. Nee, danke, ich hab schon. Nee, mach mal du den ersten Satz. Das muss ich mir merken. Ich muss nur mal sagen. Äh, zehn. Hey Florentin, willst du noch was von unserem Brokkoli haben? Ah, nee, danke, ich hab schon. Das kann man nicht natürlich sagen. Okay, ich sage es immer natürlich. Hey, Funtin, willst du noch was von unserem Brokkoli haben? Wir haben gekocht, Tim und ich.
Nee, danke, ich hab schon.
Okay, das merke ich mir, weil sonst würde ich dich einfach sonst nicht mehr anfragen, weil ich meine, and see, and see. Und so was. Und dann saß ich da und dachte mir, okay, scheiße, die hat meinen Teller nicht gesehen, weil ich im Weg war.
Das heißt, sie denkt jetzt, weil ein massiger, wulziger Körper im Weg war, ein Relaxer im Weg lag. Und dann sass ich da und dachte mir, okay, scheiße, die dachte jetzt, ich hätte ihr Essen geklaut. Was mache ich jetzt? Aber wie hat sie das denn gesagt? Na, sie hatte schon so ironisch gesagt, so wie wenn dich deine Freundin mit einer anderen Frauenbett erwischt und dann so, ja gut, aber das muss ich mir merken, see you later, ciao. Sie sagt es lustig, aber du denkst dir, na, vielleicht hat sie schon irgendwo berührt. Und so war das auch so ein bisschen, sie hat gesagt, das muss ich mir aber merken. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich würde das jetzt gerne richtig stellen, aber was mache ich denn jetzt? Und habe ich tatsächlich so gemacht, habe ich meine Wasserflasche genommen, habe die ausgekippt aus dem Fenster, um so zu tun, als ob ich neues Wasser brauchen würde, bin in die Küche gegangen, habe Wasser aufgefüllt, wo sie noch stand und dann so, während ich das Wasser auffülle, das ist immer ein bisschen unangenehm, weil das dauert halt wirklich gute 70 Sekunden, bis diese Wasserflasche aufgefüllt ist, weil es eine 8-Liter-Flasche und die muss man halt so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber man ist diese Flasche zu lang für das Waschbecken und dann muss man die so einmal in der Mitte umknicken, sodass man die unterkriegt und dann wird dann nur die obere Hälfte voller Wasser, weil dann der Knick das Wasser abtrennt und dann muss man es wieder
so aufknicken mit so einer Gelenkbewegung und dann muss es dann so in den unteren Bereich
schiessen, aber dann darf es nicht wieder nach oben laufen. Aber dann kann sie nie ganz voll machen.
Das ist, ich bin da nicht schlecht in dieser Technik, aber auf jeden Fall so und dann stehst
du da 70 Sekunden und dann wartest du 30 Sekunden und dann mal ganz kurz, als ich gerade gesagt
habe, ich habe schon, ich meinte, ich habe schon
mir eigenes Essen gemacht, ne, und nicht. Und dann saß die ganze WG bei ihrem WG-Abend da. Ja. Also sie hat, glaube ich, nicht verstanden, was ich meine. Und wie oft geht man dann nochmal hin und her und zurück und sagt, nee, also ganz kurz, du hast gesagt, also ich, nee, ich hab, erst mal gesagt. Du trinkst sehr viel, du trinkst, du hast das ganze, die ganze Acht in der Flasche, hast du jetzt ausgetrunken. Die Drierung ist wichtig, ich bin flüssiger, ich brauche Flüssigkeit. Ja, okay, wenn sie das Problem auch hatte, nicht genau zu wissen, wie du das gemeint hast und dann auch nochmal ihr Essen wegkippt, um nochmal das Essen, neue Essen zu bringen. Nochmal komplett neues Essen ko. Ich habe das nochmal Essen gebracht, weil ich es nicht genau verstanden habe, was du eben gesagt hast.
Ja, ja.
Nicht schlecht. Aber überleg mal, wenn irgendwie irgendwo ein Stamm, ein afrikanischer Stamm ohne Trinkwasser.
The tribe of the Tichipatu.
Wenn der The tribe of the Tichipatu herausfindet, dass du das Wasser rauskippst, weil du einen Satz nicht ganz verstanden hast.
Vielleicht ist es schon so ein bisschen...
Ach so, weil die kein Wasser haben, oder was?
Ja.
They don't use water, because in der Kultur water is holy, because it collects everything bad in the body. But then Klaus Kinski came and he just punches them in their bloody face.
Kinski was twenty-eight at that time and he always had those faces of extreme anger.
And when he broke out, I would always just hide.
Ist Werner Herzog der einzige Deutsche, den man am besten auf Englisch nachmachen kann? Ja, stimmt. Try to look the chicken in the eye. Herr Herzog, wie verbringen Sie Ihren Lebensabend? I don't like evening. Auf Deutsch? Sie können auch auf Deutsch nur sagen. Nee, es funktioniert nicht. Der ist ja nicht so charakteristisch. Ich würde gerne eine Impression. Impressionary. Ich mag keinen. Es funktioniert nicht, das's not working. No, no, I don't. He has always this very weight on his shoulders. Like everything he says is of great importance. It's so, as if so Sand-Säcke an seinem Kiefer befestigt sind. Yes. And it's extrem schwierig, dazwischen zu kommen. But he is always looking for the right words, but finds them. No, but he doesn't speak English. And when he was with the tribe of the Tai Chi people in the jungle. Aber das P ist auch mal Tichipatu. Der nächste Podcast ist einfach komplett als Werner Herzog. Also immer einladen. Moment, ich glaube, er ist sogar gerade hier komisch, dass du das sagst. Ah, er ist hier. Hallo, Herr Herzog. Ja, auf jeden Fall bin ich der schlimmste Mitbewohner aller Zeiten. Und ich habe auch, ich glaube einfach sehr viel und es ist mir sehr ungenehm. Ich weiss nicht, wie das jetzt alles rüberkommt. Ich weiss nicht, wie viel ich meine WG-Geschichten erzählen darf, weil ich weiss nicht, ob meine Mitbewohner nicht vielleicht den Podcast hören. Also das sind aber so komische Sachen. Ich weiss immer nicht, ob die mich nicht auf Sachen hinweisen wollen, weil es hat zum Beispiel bei uns in der WG jeder ein eigenes Regal und letztens haben die mein Regal aufgeräumt. Kamen die nach Hause und ich habe da so ganz viele Chai-Tee-Dosen. Was ist dein Regal? Wie muss man sich dein Regal vorstellen? Voller Chai-Tee-Dosen. Nee, erst mal ist es eine Han Solo-Actionfigur. Erst mal Han Solo-Actionfigur. So, dann Chai-Tee. Dann Chai-Tee, ganz viele Chai-Tee, Decaf, Giraffe, Tukan, Mango, einfach nur diese Boxen da, dann Milchpulver natürlich eine ganze Menge und ich habe noch Pfefferminzmarmelade, die habe ich immer noch. Und so ein Bad, so ein Erholungsschaumbad oder so.
Wir haben ja in New York diesen Haul gemacht, wo wir die ganzen Sachen gekauft haben, und da hatte ich auch diese Pfefferminzen-Marmelade.
Übrigens, nächste Woche gibt es wieder einen Haul, den zweiten Haul.
Wirklich? Die Pfefferminzen-Marmelade habe ich immer noch.
Weil die so scheisse ist, dass man sie...
Nee, weil ich die, ich habe Respekt davor, die aufzumachen, sonst so, ja, weiß ich nicht.
Nicht so schlecht.
Ich denke oft an New York, ich denke oft an diesen Supermarkt. Ich will auch nochmal nach New York. Dieser Supermarkt war echt geil, ey. Oh, ich will auch so nach New York. Ich habe auch immer gedacht, will mir gerade auch jemand einen Hinweis geben, dass er meinen Podcast hört? Was natürlich so ein bisschen narzisstisch ist, weil das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass jemand, den man halbwegs kennt, da weiß ich nicht. Aber der ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich. Und jemand hat zu mir gesagt, ja, du hast ja auch viel Geld. Und ich so, wie meinst du das?
Ja, Geld.
Viel Geld. Und ich habe gesagt, wie, wie, hä, wie meinst du das jetzt? Ja, so viel krass, als wenn du die kaufst. Und ich so, Moment mal kurz. Aber da war ich auch nicht schlagfertig genug, um uns direkt zu fragen, ja, hast du den Podcast gehört, oder? Ja. Sondern direkt so, ja, genau. Habe ich eigentlich schon mal erzählt, dass ich, als ich das Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt anhatte, bin ich in Hamburg durch die Gegend gelaufen und dann hat mich jemand angesprochen so, ah, hörst du auch das Podcast-Ufo? Und ich so, ja, und dann 21, 23, und er hat erst gar nicht gerafft, dass ich es bin, er dachte nur, ich bin einfach ein Hörer. Geil! Hörst du auch das Podcast-Ufo? Ja, gelegentlich. Ich habe mir nicht so oft gerne meine Stimme an.
Liebe Grüße an Rügen, an die Stadt Rügen, gute Insel, Kongas. Also, wir haben es euch versprochen, wir haben euch gesagt, ihr bekommt es in Folge 74. 74, 74, ist es überlegs so weit.
Da kommt wieder Ralf Ruther oder so was. Können wir mal gucken.
Sie hören nun mit der Interpretation des vierten Violinkonzerts von Johann Sebastian Brahms,
gespielt auf der Conga-Inzidur von Stefan Tietze.
Dankeschön.
Ich würde mir gerne mal ein Konzert anhören.
Aber warum hast du jetzt alles voller Vaseline gemacht?
Kriegst du keine Vaseline-Bazen?
Follow-up-Gag. Wie heissen die nochmal?
Follow-up?
Throwback.
Throwback. Nee, Throwback. Throwback.
Nee, Callback. Callback. Callback, sorry.
Das kriegen wir beide nie hin.
Ah ja, wir lassen.
Sehr interessant.
Danke.
Worüber wollten wir heute sprechen?
Heute war doch eine Spelchefunde.
Wir wollten über Tod sprechen, weil da ein Fisch im Sterben liegt.
Würdest du ihn denn beerdigen? Also was machst du, sobald du keinen Puls mehr spülst?
Spülst.
Ah, fuck, Alter, ey. Was ist denn jetzt noch passiert? Nein! Hey, was ist passiert? Ich habe eine offene Wunde am Fuß, weil ich gestern die unbequemsten Schuhe der Menschheitsgeschichte anhat. Du kriegst offene Wunden durch Schuhe? Ja. Du trägst Schuhe nur aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen, du trägst offene Schuhe, du trägst auf nur Socken, dicke Socken, Rutsche Socken. Nein, ich habe gestern gedreht und es ist, also man denkt sich ja so, okay, es gibt so eine Hierarchie am Set, es gibt den Regisseur, es gibt die Maskenfrauen, es gibt oder Männer oder Pferde, je nachdem, und es gibt verschiedene Hierarchien. So, aber eigentlich die mächtigste Position am Set und bei jedem Film und bei jedem Dreh und bei jeder Produktion ist das Kostüm, weil du kannst Leonardo DiCaprio sein, du kannst drei Oscars gewonnen haben, es gibt nichts demütigenderes, als wenn dir jemand eine Hose rauslegt, die drei Nummern zu klein ist und du dann im Kostüm stehst und die anzwängst und dann irgendwann sagst, tut mir leid, die ist zu klein. Das ist natürlich die Schuld des Kostüms, weil die deine Grösse falsch haben, aber trotzdem, die können dich fertig machen einfach. Das ist mir schon so schon so ein bisschen Insider-Gag. Die paar Einspieler, die ich zu sehen war beim Neo-Magazin, hat das Kostüm mir konstant, obwohl sie meine Grösse kennen, zu kleine Hosen besorgt. Und jedes Mal stehe ich da, sorry, ich schaff's einfach nicht. Und jedes Mal höre ich den Satz, oh, du bist echt dicker als man erwartet. Und beim vierten Mal habe ich dann transparent gemacht, das sagt der mir fucking jedes Mal. Was macht der, dem müde ich mich einfach. Ich glaube, das machen die auch mit Absicht, weil wirklich, also ich glaube, also du kannst ja wirklich, wenn du einen Schauspieler hast, kannst du den ja als Kostümmensch einfach kaputt machen. Die sind ja oft recht eitel, aber du kannst die in echt enge Hosen, unbequeme Schuhe machen die einfach den Tag kaputt. Du kannst den schönsten Tag der Welt haben mit den nettesten Menschen der Welt. Wenn du Schuhe hast, die drei Nummern zu klein sind, ist dein Tag scheisse, egal was passiert. Richtig. Du kannst von einem Einhorn eingeblasen bekommen, mit den falschen Schuhen ist es einfach falsch. Stellt mir nicht so geil vor, auch weil es andauernd ein Horn in deinem Magen piekst. Ja gut, das sind dann die Opfer, die man bringen muss, ja das stimmt schon. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist einfach schrecklich. Und das Problem ist, ich hatte Stiefel an, die mir von der Fussgrösse gepasst haben, aber meine Unterschenkel waren zu dick. Also ich habe von der Schuhgrösse und ich habe auch reingepasst, aber die Unterschenkel waren zu dick. Und dann haben die sich so nach unten gestaucht und dann haben die halt so ganz komisch die ganze Zeit rumgerieben an meinen Füssen und seitlich und so. Und dadurch habe ich halt die ganze Fussseite so aufgerissen und da ist eine offene Wunde und das ist ganz schrecklich. Wollte ich nur sagen, weil ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, es tut weh. Ich habe dem Kostüm damit so ein bisschen Geld zugesteckt, damit sich so ein bisschen Schmirgelpapier reinlegt, so ein bisschen Stacheldraht reinlegt. Ja, aber das sind auch so Punkte, wo man einfach merkt, man hat einen unförmigen Körper, wenn anscheinend die Füsse passen, aber die Unterschenkel dann zu dick sind. Du hast ja ein Typ, der diese Stiefel gemacht hat, dann denkt man, ja Menschen mit der und der Schuhgrosse haben eine so und so grosse Schenkeldicke und du denkst dir, nein, nicht mich. Meine Theorie ist auch, man will individuell sein, man will was Besonderes sein, ausser wenn es um deinen Körper geht. Du willst den durchschnittlichsten Körper der Welt haben. Du willst normal gut aussehen, du willst am liebsten keine Locken haben, du willst, also, nur offens, aber du willst eigentlich nicht aussehen, du willst eine normale Figur haben, du willst eine normale Proportion haben, du willst alles normal haben, du brauchst keine Besonderheiten mit dem Körper. Aber das ist echt so, wenn es nicht zusammenpasst, ich glaube, wenn mein Körper ein Puzzle wäre, man hätte grosse Schwierigkeiten, weil die einzelnen Teile einfach nicht gut zueinander passen, wenn du denkst so, die wurde falsch geliefert, ich ruf nochmal bei Hass, ah jetzt bei Ravensburger. Es ist ein Anschlussfehler, so. Da wäre etwas schief gelaufen, aber es ist halt so. Dein Körper ist ein Anschlussfehler. Es passt einfach nicht zusammen. Aber hast du schon mal beim Dreh mitgespielt? Ja, manchmal Dreh ist es sehr lustig. Ich darf aber nicht verraten, was wir drehen, aber es wird spannend. Es wird cool. Man darf ja nicht sagen. Gut, Stefan, was hast du heute noch vor? Schön aufs Fahrrad schwingen? Nee, ich, ähm, ich hab, nee, also ich will einfach, ich will nach Hause, ich will schlafen und ich will noch ein bisschen trauern. Wie trauern, wie gehst du mit dem Stichwort Tod um? Also, wie, ist schon mal jemand gestorben, also wirklich ein nahe Verwandter gestorben? Ja, schon, aber ich glaube, ich gehe damit immer recht, eigentlich relativ gut um. Aber wir sind sehr rationale Menschen, wir sind emotionslos, wir sind steinkalt, wir haben ein Herz aus Wolle. Und wir wissen nicht, ich weiß nicht, also ich bin sehr rational und kann damit ganz gut leben. Wie, wie, wie gehst du damit um? Also es kommt darauf an, ne, also es kommt darauf an, wenn jetzt, glaube ich, jemand sterben würde, von dem man es nicht erwartet, glaube ich, ist es schon noch was anderes. Ja, klar. Als wenn jetzt die Grosseltern sterben würde, oder so, da wirst du halt seit Jahren durch Simpsons Episoden oder Folgen und halt auch durch das Konzept Erbe, also ich glaube, das Konzept Erbe wurde auch einfach deswegen eingeführt, wenn man sich dachte, ja, das mit dem Sterben ist echt scheiße. Sie ist tot, aber ihr kriegt diesen Besen und diese SS-Uniform. Danke! Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es auch ganz okay. Nein, ich habe wirklich noch keine so allzu schweren Erfahrungen damit gemacht. Okay. Ja, ich finde es spannend. Meine Katze ist gestorben so mal. Also wir hatten eine Katze bekommen, als ich geboren wurde, gleichzeitig, also es ist eine Art Schwester für mich gewesen. Und die hat mich auch viel erzogen, also dann auch viel gebabysittet für mich die Katze. Du machst auch manchmal diese Geste, wo du mit deinem Handrücken so über deinen Mund und die, also manchmal so ablegst. Nee, es ist einfach die beste Art, um irgendwie seinen Nacken zu säubern. Wenn du dich am Ohr kratzt, du machst auch manchmal so ganz schnelle Bewegungen, wo man sich denkt, ist es für eine Katze zum Tatschen? Ich beiße auch manchmal einfach so random in mein Bein rein und dann entscheide dann plötzlich, dass mein Bein feindlich ist. Es gibt wirklich Menschen, die von Pferden, von Vögeln, es gibt wirklich Menschen, die von Gorillas grossgewacht worden sind. Ja. Das ist ja kein Hoax, das ist ja wirklich passiert. Es gibt wirklich Menschen, die von Gorillas grossgezogen worden sind. Das ist total geil, wissen viele nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung darüber zu erzählen, aber es ist wirklich spannend. Es gab diesen Wolfsjungen und dann hat man diesen Wolfsjungen gesehen und dann hatte der auch Fail. Dann hielten sie so, Moment mal jetzt, aber dass der von Wölfen aufgezogen wird, hatte der nicht einfach Fail, dann war er vielleicht ein Comic oder einf, ich weiss es nicht genau. Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, keine Ahnung. Ja, aber es gibt von Dimitri Martin, einen Comedian, den wir beide sehr cool finden, der hat ein Buch geschrieben und da gibt es so eine Kurzgeschichte darüber, über den Sohn von jemandem, der von Wölfen aufgezogen wird. Alle reden nur über den Vater, der nur von den Wölfen aufgezogen wurde. Viel schlimmer ist es, der Sohn von dem Vater zu sein, der Mensch ist, aber aufgezogen wurde von Wölfen, die Eigenschaft von Wölfen hat, aber nicht so aussieht. Er kann nicht sagen, ich wurde von Wölfen großgezogen. Das ist eine coole Geschichte. Der Sohn hat es viel schlimmer noch. Der geht mit normalen Leuten in die Schule und muss mit dem komischen Vater. Er hat auch einen normalen Vater, denkt man. Wenn die Katze gestorben ist, das war schon echt traurig. Da hat sie dann so ein Bart mit einer Fussbotenheizung. Und da hat sie sich dann hingelegt und dann hat die lange nicht mehr gefressen und dann so und dann war ich da auch immer oft und habe neben ihr gelegen und habe ihr was zu fressen gegeben und alle möglichen Sachen so um sie rum gestellt, so ob sie auf irgendwas Lust hat und habe ja verschiedene Sachen angeboten. Minen, Minen um sie rum. Und dann einfach lag die da rum und hatte gar nichts mehr gemacht und dann dachte ich mir, gut, damit kann ich mich anfreunden und dann, ja, aber irgendwann war sie dann weg.
Man hatte dann Messer.
Ist sie verschwunden wie so ein Lini?
Die ist einfach so in sich zusammengesackt.
Es blieb so ein Lini.
Nee, die war von einer Stunde auf die nächste total steif.
Also die war, ja mein so, und dann hat man sie immer so gestreichelt und dann irgendwann war die ganz steif und dann war sie einfach tot.
Und dann konnte man die wie so eine Uzi, so ein Maschinengewehr, so in die Hand nehmen und dann konnte man damit so...
So tun, als hätte man eine Katzenknarre.
Ja, nee, und dann haben wir die gegessen.
Nee, man ist tatsächlich in unserem Garten vergraben, darf man nicht, aber haben wir...
Darf man nicht?
Nee, man darf keine Katzen vergraben.
Aber wählen Sie dich hier. Ich frage für einen Freund. Das weiss ich nicht. Ich glaube, die muss man entweder im Klo runterspülen oder offiziell bestatten lassen in einem Sarg. Aber ich glaube, man darf die generell nicht begraben, weil die irgendwie so Katzen... Aber ich weiss gar nicht, warum eigentlich, weil rein rechtlich sind ja Tiere immer noch Gegenstände. Wenn du eine Katze vom Nachbarn tötest, ist es eine Sachbeschädigung. Das ist ganz seltsam. Einfach so, da gibt es kein Zwischending, entweder es ist Mensch oder es ist halt dann alles andere Objekt, aber es gibt da keine Strafe für Tiere. Darf ich eine Kommode begraben? Ne, das wär halt dann, ne, das hast du sowieso nicht, das ist halt gegen das Ordnungsamt, du darfst keinen Müll oder Sperrmüll, einfach so, irgendwie so in Waschmaschinen oder sowas, im Garten vergraben. Ist ja Biomüll dann? Eine Katze. Eine Truhe. Eine Katze, die kannst du einfach in Biomüll schmeißen. Nimm da mit, Jungs, ne? Das war eine harte Zeit, Stefan. Ich will nicht, dass du dich darüber lustig machst. Aber wir haben eine neue Katze gekauft, die war dann süss und klein und dann war die alte auch scheissegal. Naja, aber hat schon ganz gut funktioniert. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich eine gute Möglichkeit, einfach das Ersetzen, Ersatz. Das Konzept Haustiere ist auch ganz strange. Also was sind Haustiere? Halb Freund, halb Geisel. Ja, es stimmt schon. Und vor allem ist es so, also auch so, wenn man Dinge mag, dann sollte man sie eigentlich nicht einsperren. Oder alleine halten müssen. Das ist so eine sehr narzisstische Art. Ich mag Tiere, ich mag aber nur die Aspekte, die sich mit meinem Alltag kombinieren lassen. Oh, die rennen im Wald rum und jagen Menschen und sind wild. Nee, das trainieren wir denen ab. Das ist nicht gut. Das ist nicht der Teil des Tieres, den ich mag. Nein, nein, Sitz, nein, nein, nicht mich fressen. Ich mag, dass sie mir die Zeitung an die Couch bringt. Das finde ich gut, das belassen wir bei. Das heißt, du magst etwas, manipulierst es aber dann so stark. Das ist wie so eine ungesunde Beziehung, wenn du jemanden magst, aber ihn versuchst so zu manipulieren, dass es eingenehm ist. Gut, jetzt sagt man aber, die wurden so lange domestiziert, dass irgendwann ist deren im Wald rumrennen und Kanickeljagen, ist es, die neue Zeitung wegbringen. Vielleicht ist das ja jetzt ihr neues Ding. Und es wäre genauso tierverachtend, wenn man die jetzt in den Wald schickt und sagt, lauf, lauf, hol das Tier, nicht die Zeitung, das Tier. Weiss man nicht. Ja, du hast recht. Ja, ich weiss. Ja, das ist echt ein ganz, ganz komisches Konzept. Haustiere. Ich überlege mir jetzt so eine Vogelspinne zu holen, weil da musst du nichts machen.
Die kriegt dann mal irgendwann so einen Küken reingeworfen oder so, keine Ahnung was die fressen, und dann bringen die das brutal um und dann ist gut. Ey, wenn du so weitermachst, hast du irgendwann RTL vor der Tür, da hast du noch so Bilder, die aus verschiedenen Bildern bestehen an der Wand hängen, da hast du so eine Vogelspinne, so einen Fliesentisch und so, die generiert so ganz langsam. So Bilder, die aus anderen Bildern bestehen. Das stimmt.
Das ist so, ja, und so einen Kalender, Bilder, die aus anderen Bildern bestehen. Das stimmt.
Und so einen ganz normalen Kalender zu haben.
Ich hoffe, dass ich nie so einen normalen Kalender habe.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Das ist ein klassisches RTL-Requisit.
Das sagt er mir auch bei diesem legendären Halt-Stop bei Frauentausch, wo er sie anschreit und dann rausrennt.
Und dann schlägt er die Tür so zu und dann hängen zwei Kalender an der Wand übereinander.
Und der eine fällt runter. Das ist so ein normaler Tierkalender und darunter ist so ein Pornokalender, so als hätte er ihn versteckt, aber ich dachte mir, das ist dramaturgisch so perfekt gemacht, dass er gerade rausstürmt und die Tür zuschlägt und dadurch er auch noch gedemütigt wird, weil er sich rausstellt, dass er a diesen Pornokalender hat und b ihn für den Dreh verstecken wollte, wo ich mir denke, also entweder ist es sehr, sehr gut hingebastelt. Und wie, das kriegt man natürlich besser inszeniert. Oder ist es halt, oder ist es halt dann wirklich alles fake, auch dass er in dem Moment rausrennt und in dem Moment halt die Tür zuschlägt und sowas gut sein kann. Oder mit so einem Seil so gezogen wurde an den Kalender. Ja, genau, sowas in der Richtung. Aber das ist schon echt verrückt. Geil, das ist nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, die krassesten Special-Effekte in Filmen ist auch sowas und nicht, wir lassen da was Explodierendes statt, sondern eher sowas, genau in dem Moment fällt der Kalender runter und es muss halt so aussehen, ob der einfach nur runterfällt. Das sind so ganz alltägliche Dinge, genau wie bei Stanley Kubrick bei 2001 ist er quasi die erste Szene, wie sie im Raumschiff fliegen, wie er mit diesem Airline, Shuttle Service zur Station gebracht wird. Und dann fliegt der Kugelschreiber, fliegt ihm aus seiner Tasche, aus seiner Bustasche und wird dann von ihr eingesammelt, von der Flugbeleiterin und wird wieder in die Tasche gelegt. Und da habe ich nicht darüber nachgedacht, wenn ich das Ding geguckt habe, wie krass das aussieht für die Zeit. Und dann habe ich irgendwann herausgefunden, wie die das gemacht haben. Die haben eine Glasscheibe genommen, so einfach, und haben einfach einen Kugelschreiber drangeklebt. Und dann haben die Glasscheibe halt so bewegt, als ob der Kugelschreiber fliegt, und dann man Glas nicht sieht. Warum sieht man Glas nicht? Spiegelung. Man sieht Glas nicht. Und dann hat man halt nur den Kugelschreiber gesehen. Mega genial. Und das war auch die erste Verwendung von doppelseitigem Klebeband. Ja? Weiß ich nicht. Glaub schon. Kann gut sein. Nehmt die Fakten unabhängig von ihrem Wahrheitsgehalt auf. Take the facts, Babes! Take the facts! Deal with it! Deal with it! Hast du noch was zu erzählen? Eine spannende Anekdote, eine spannende Geschichte? Überhaupt nicht. Ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche. Viel Spaß und haut rein. Ansonsten bis nächste Woche. Thema nächste Woche. Spinnen! Spinnen. Werden wir uns anschauen, ob Stefan sich tatsächlich seinen lieb gewordenen Fisch tatsächlich einfach so kaltherzig und skrupellos ersetzt hat durch einen neuen Begleiter in seinem Leben. Ob er gestorben ist und nicht? Aber nächste Woche? Oh Gott, das ist so herzlos. Die Leute werden einschalten, auf jeden Fall, die wollen wissen, wann er stirbt.
Ja, man muss aus so einer Trauer dann auch so ein Verkaufsargument schlagen.
Er hat PR verdient, Jeff, es war ein guter Fisch.
War ein guter Fisch.
Also ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut bis dahin, haut rein und ich
glaube, wie ich würde es einfach sagen, wir hängen einfach ab, oder?